let's talk about Lindsay Lohan now it
seemed like healthy things were going
pretty well for Lindsay she's been
shooting her new MTV reality show in
Greece and then over the weekend well
Lindsay's life took a bizarre turn I can
help feel welcome some of what you need
in a sense deleted Instagram live from
Moscow Lohan speaking Arabic Russian and
English with an accent becomes
infuriated when a homeless family
refuses her help the actors trails them
throwing out this allegation they're
trafficking children when she tries to
grab a child this woman seemingly makes
contact the scuffle leaving Lindsay in
tears are you Harvey because you look
fully loaded SNL put fun Twitter lit up
with outrage some labeling it an
attempted kidnapping others puzzled by
her accent I won't leave until I take
you I have a lot of good people around
me like very strong women not n tiny
friends up in Dubai we kind of noticed
an accent emerging last year when
Lindsay told us why she prefers living
overseas I do love the serenity and
peace that I find living in the Middle
East because there are no cameras in
Dubai so I can have a private life with
all the social media in the world these
days it's really impossible to have that
here
[Music]